I've been dealing with this since I was
5 years old I'm almost 18 I just want to
move on to the next chapter of my life
and that money was going to help me do
it that North Carolina girl was supposed
to get thousands of dollars after she
won a lawsuit against the man who
sexually abused her but she won't see a
dime why because police seized her
abuser's money via civil forfeiture when
menhill police went to investigate her
abuser they found weed in his apartment
cops use that as justification to seize
about $70,000 from him although he was
never charged with a drug crime civil
forfeiture allows law enforcement to
take the assets without charging them
with a related offense cops say they
need to seize assets to fight crime but
No One Believes the abuser of $70,000
was funding a weed drug ring record show
he'd won that in a lottery police
reportedly told the victim's family to
file a lawsuit and seek a settlement she
won but there was no money left the
government kept it all police should
never profit off of the victims they
claimed to protect